Desiree who is now pregnant with her  first child a met her husband on The  Bachelorette and she's helping Brides to  beat with her new book my fairy tale  wedding planning your dream wedding  without breaking the bank I just really  wanted to be able to help them get  through wedding planning stress free  there's just so much stuff that can be  really overwhelming and right so the  hard time but it's really like  prioritizing what's most important to  you as a couple is it the guest list or  is it gonna be the dancing for us we  really wanted to have a good party and  have our guests just all on the dance  floor well I've seen so many  stressed-out Brides that I didn't want  to be that bright so I was really cared  for and that day was special and  everything really worked out as it  should you can have everything you want  with any budget but our wedding was  definitely everything that we wanted so  it was a fairy tale to us